[Music]
[Applause]
hello learners welcome to our
environmental science in a secondary
course of an RS in our previous program
we have already discussed about modern
agriculture which includes process of
processing food feed - an agriculture
vation of the certain plants and raising
of domesticated animal so today there is
a great demand to promote sustainable
agriculture there is less than twenty
one concept of sustainable agriculture
of module six first level development
MLM cook tacos cognitive involved in
science welcome to you in this program
look at the figure as we know that
primitive humans discovered agriculture
about 12,000 years ago primitive hunters
and gatherers move to pace near rivers
once humans knew that watering plant is
necessary to grow plants look at the
left side figure hunting and godrick
primitive humans learn to become farmers
such human settlements begin forming
gradually more human settled away from
rivers and water they're going crops
with water from wells to bills and other
means of withdrawing groundwater
however result of farming depending
largely on rains during monsoon right
side figure shows a farmer playing rain
God now come to the objective of the
program are relate changing human needs
with overuse of environment need for
enhancing quality of environment define
sustainable agriculture and justify its
need describe concept and methods of
sustainable agriculture explain about
organic farming and its benefits
describe the methods of preparing one we
composed explained bio fertilizer and
they are used in agriculture explain
integrated pest management and Jean GMOs
and its related issues now come to
humanist and over you know environment
human population are growing rapidly
throughout the world almost half of the
population live in densely populated
urban areas rural population migrate
to open areas in search of job food
housing and a better lifestyle and also
impact on agriculture as well as
environment now come to the need for
enhanced quality of environment this
huge population puts a tremendous
pressure on resources the high rate of
consumption of resources and highways
rate as expansion of cities Copeland's
forests wetland and wild habitat destroy
so there is a great need to improve the
situation so that humans can enjoy a
quality environment we do deserve a
healthy environment to survive and lead
a good life now come to the advent of
modern agriculture after world war ii
food and fiber were raised by new
technology
thus begin modern agriculture use of new
machines and implements for agriculture
use of fertilizers and pesticides
expansion of irrigation facilities
result in enough food for fast-growing
population now come to the impact of
modern agriculture on environment
population increased more food needed
more farm used agriculture grow more
food but many adverse effects on
environment and unemployment of farm
labourers come to the impact on
environment deforestation to get land
for agriculture top soil depletion soil
pollution another one groundwater
contamination polluted water
unemployment of farm laborers migrating
from villages to cities resulting in
urbanization and its problems next slide
shows different tools and implements and
expansion of irrigation facilities now
come to the sustainable agriculture to
saw through gun of last two decades
remote not modern agriculture but
sustained
culture to save the environment for
future generations
next question arises what is sustainable
agriculture and sustainable agriculture
for whom sustainable agriculture or
systemic farming attempts to produce
sufficient food exhausting soil
fertility and damaging environment it is
to be least toxic komlin and least
energy intensive in operation and get
maintain productivity and profitability
grow sufficient food and retain soil
quality for many subsequent generation
to grow food now how does sustainable
agriculture achieve so answer is it can
be achieved by various ways that is
protect and preserve environmental
quality use natural resources
judiciously decrease dependence on
non-renewable energy resources provide
consumers with affordable high-quality
foodstuff support profitable agriculture
production enhance quality of life of
farmers and rural population last for
many generations now come to the methods
of sustainable agriculture that will be
mixed cropping or diverse coughing crop
rotation multiple cropping while
planning these approaches one has to be
kept in mind local geography and
topography nature and condition of soil
so local climate and local inputs and
farmers goal now we will discuss
objectives of sustainable agriculture
cultivation practices to increase
biological and economic stability
selection of improved varieties to suit
the need soil management by proper
method of tillage many farmers in India
and other developing countries follow
the traditional practices of mixed
cropping or diverse cropping and crop
rotation first ability mixed cropping or
diverse copying is an old practices
India in this method two or more crops
are grown on the same piece of land and
at the same time this removes the
insecurities of total crop failure when
more than one crop is grown at least one
pill survived if not all of the two
crops grown together one is a long
duration crop and other a short duration
cob nutrients required by the two crops
is different time of maturity is
different
generally leguminous crop is grown with
a main crop so nitrogen gets fixed and
there is no need for fertilizer
it saves costs other plants for mixed
cropping can be Polly varietal
punctuation that is several varieties of
same crop grown together now next is
intercropping different crops that is
banach leguminous crop which fixes
nitrogen other carbohydrate crop which
uses soil nitrogen plants maturing at
different times are grown together needs
different so less inputs needed natural
predators control pace so new pesticides
needed compared to monoculture yield per
hectare much more now what is
monoculture it is a cultivation of
single crop on large scale which gives
large eat but for a short period of time
it is expensive as lots of fertilizers
and pesticides are needed
so not only monoculture is economically
unsound but also environmentally harmful
next is crop rotation growing different
crops in succession regularly in the
same field result control insects and
diseases increase soil fertility
decreases soil erosion monoculture of
high yield single crop exhaust totally
one certain minerals yield remain
utilization
this result in nutrient imbalance of the
soil and increases certain pastes and
diseases sewing a leguminous crop as a
rotational crop is very useful because
legumes enhance nitrogen label in the
soil due to their ability to fix
atmospheric nitrogen reduces that need
for chemical nitrogen fertilizer thereby
cutting the cost and saving the soil
from the harmful effects of using high
yielding varieties along with the
application of large amount of
fertilizers pesticides and water it is
possible to grow two or sometimes three
different crops in succession on the
same length with inner ear is known as
multiple cropping this practice can go
on for some time but the length can not
maintain high eat in a long run crop
rotation takes in two among the factors
first leguminous crops should be clone
after non leguminous crop crop requires
less water should be clone after one
that requires more water
third crops requiring less meat meal
should be shown after one that require
more menus important crop patterns of
propagation as shown in this slide first
green gram wheat and move second round
net weight and move third order
sugarcane beet and more food paddy beet
and move mixed cropping when coupled
with livestock rearing has many
advantages some land area can be used or
crop of grown on one label and steeper
slope if pasture and leguminous forages
crops are rotated soil quality is
enhanced livestock menu makes while for
time in
case of rainfall at least livestock
provided milk takes marketing of
multiple products easy cushions for
farmers against price fluctuation farm
labor gets utilized more effectively now
come to the soil management a healthy
soil is a key component of sustainable
agriculture that is healthy soil along
with water and nutrient produces healthy
crop plants that are less susceptible to
pests and diseases accordingly soil must
be protected and nurtured to ensure
long-term productivity and stability
methods of protection include using
cover crops shampoos reducing tillage
conserving soil moisture by dead mulches
this increases water hold capacity of
the soil significant improvement in crop
production has been achieved by using
the conventional method of selection and
plant breeding now objectives of
varietal improvement improvement are
development of high yielding varieties
of crop plants food crops develop for
better and higher nutritional quality
like protein quality in pulses making
quality in wheat preserving quality in
fruits and vegetables soil quality in
oil seed producing plants developmental
of crop varieties resistance to disease
and paste improving varieties for
resistance against heat cold frost
draught and water logging now come to
the bio fertilizer and its uses in
agriculture while fertilizer are
substitutes for chemical fertilizers
such as NPK they are used in reduces
energy expenditure required to
manufacture fertilizers they do not
cause pollution microorganisms like
bacteria algae and fungi fix atmospheric
nitrogen debt can be solubilized
phosphorus decomposed organic material
or oxidized sulfur in soil
enhance
growth and yield of crops improve soil
fertility some of the important types of
biofertilizers which can be considered
for agro based industries are Rhizobium
as ito bacterium zola blue-green algae
etcetera first Rhizobium it is a
symbiotic bacteria and form do not use
in leguminous plants and live there they
can fix atmospheric nitrogen up to 200
kilo gram nitrogen per hectare per year
surplus nitrogen remains in soil and
enhanced soil quality
next is Agito bacteria these are aerobic
fix living nitrogen fixing bacteria grow
around foods of cereals and fixed
nitrogen reduce growth promoting
hormones which helps in enhancing growth
and yield of plants next is a spiral um
aerobic fix living nitrogen fixing
bacteria associate symbiotic bacteria
live on wood surface of host plant and
increase crop yield supplying growth
hormones and vitamins commonly used in
commercial inoculation next is blue gill
algae no stock and anabaena are common
blue green algae or cyanobacteria free
living and photosynthetic they fixed
nitrogen use in flooded rice fields as
nitrogen biofertilizers next is a Zola
it is a water fun inside which grows
nitrogen fixing VG anabaena ozuna and
nabina combine is used as fertilizer in
all over the world
it grows in summer makes is phosphorous
solubilizing biofertilizers phosphorus
is needed for plant root also for not
dual formation Rhizobium
certain microbes solubilize phosphorus
and make it available for plants to
absorb now we will discuss my cruiser
fungi that occur on roots of forest
trees and crop plants in soil low in
available nutrients there is an
increased absorption of nutrients by
plants infected by mike rizzo the fungus
has the ability to dissolve and absorb
phosphorus that plant roots cannot
readily absorb now come to the organic
farming and its benefit organic matter
is bought living organisms are made of
hence organic farming in agriculture
relying on crop rotation crop residue
animal menu like you in menu organic
waste and biofertilizers mechanical
control cultivation mineral bearing
crops biological pest and weed control
in other parts organic farming does not
use any chemicals or artificial
substance for agriculture agricultural
product for organic farming are green
dairy products poultry products cotton
and jute fibres flowers etc thus organic
farming creates a sustainable lifestyle
for generations to come now come to the
method of organic farming nourishing
microbes in soil to provide its
nutrients soil organic matter gives the
soil good structure and water holding
capacity organic farmers grow these
microbes and add compost and biological
based soil nutrients so that plants
grown in organic farm our disease and
pest resistant organic farmers use crop
rotation to in ditch soil continuously
and keep up a paste prefer specific
crops to keep pests away predators are
used meeting is disrupted and tress
and barriers are used now come to the
benefits of organic farming it can be
learnt easily by farmer reduce
production cost as expensive fertilizers
and pesticides not used did you say soil
erosion up to 50% increase crop eat
fivefold in lowland
organic farms can support wildlife as
the animal can roam in pastures and
grace entire ecosystem along with
groundwater is improved varies benefits
as the cattle are fed organic field and
grazes on organic fields these kettles
are more healthy and kept tasty milk
soil remains healthy with living
microbes that provide the soil with
micronutrients soil gets inexhaustible
nutrients for many generations of crops
roll in the organic field quality of
products enhanced as they are free from
harmful chemicals artificial flavors
colors and preservatives now come to the
advantages of intense farming and
organic formula in short advantage of
intensive farming are bigger eats from
land available fewer Parker's native use
of hormone increases meat production
large numbers of animals kept in ideal
conditions produced a sleeper fewer
blemishes on crops and organic farming
soil structure is better less harmful to
environment no harmful chemicals
healthier more birds insects and animals
lead happier lives now come to the Burma
compost
Burma compost can be prepared at the
back yard of your home in one corner to
your school field or may be public park
which will produce manure as well as
clean up the environment from garbage
accumulation when we composting
efficient
lyric cycles organic waste crop residues
and agro industrial waste art forms and
microbes includes bacteria and fungi
together turn organic waste into useful
organic menu now we would like to talk
about augering materials that can be
required for vermicompost it can be
agricultural residue dry organic waste
waste vegetable so we have been residues
weeds sugarcane tress city culture
residue from silk production animal
menus dairy and poultry bills waste food
industry waste municipal solid waste
biogas large veggies from sugar cane
factories now come to the steps in
making public compost will not purchase
bombs from your wormy compost Minh
prepare the bomb bedding motion the
bedding add a handful of soil to be to
the bedding add the bombs to the
vermicompost win at food scripts - bin
to the win remove the warmth when the
compost is done harvest a bomb we
composed replace the bedding and
reintroduced the bombs now next is
integrated pest management farmers
develop a control program that includes
cultivation biological and chemical
methods applied in proper sequence with
and with the proper timing the aim of
IPM is not a eradicate the base
population completely but to keep the
crop damage to economically tolerable
level farmers monitored the field and
when they find the paste label to be
high enough they first used biological
methods and cultivation practices to
control and then use small amounts of
insecticides mostly insecticides derived
from plant as
last resort biological controls include
natural predator parasites and pathogens
of the paste are used examples are first
based on two combi plant called red
spider mite is controlled by using a
predatory mite that fed on red spider
mite second set red food in California
heavily damaged by a scale insects which
were controlled by Australian ladybird
which are Aveda insects mealy bug paste
of cassava plant were controlled by
parasitoid wasp which was its initial
enemy hormones are used that disturb the
insects normal life cycle thereby
preventing it from reaching maturity and
reproducing and multiplying now come to
the biotechnology in agriculture modern
agriculture you assured in Green
Revolution with hybrid seeds fertilizers
pesticides and improvement in
agriculture practices genetic
engineering our recombinant DNA
technology brought in second Green
Revolution with genetically modified GM
crops or transgenic crops on GMOs
transgenic crops have been produced with
the following aims crop resistance to
herbicides crop resistance to insects
and diseases atmospheric nitrogen
fixation by cereal crops tolerance to
high salt soil and to flooding in crops
rot resistance in crop improving
nutritional quality of crops prolonging
shelf life of fruits and vegetables so
some important examples of transgenics
or GMOs are bt cotton produced by
incorporating batesian with encodes for
BT toxins in the cotton plant the plant
becomes insect resistance and
this gene has been incorporated in
brinjal corn potato tomato tobacco
Osetra making them insect resistance
such plants can reduce our dependence on
chemical pesticides which will save us
money and our environment Golden Rice
our transgenic with enhanced with I mean
a content producing nutritionally rich
rice to save many lives salt and what
tolerance genes have been incorporated
in rice so that BT rice in China shows
higher yield and health and a huge
reduction in pesticides used such rice
can be grown on saline soil Nexus by
slowing down and controlling ripening in
tomato by introducing a bacterial genes
that prevents a higher information thus
delaying ripening such tomatoes are easy
to handle during transportation and
remains on the shelf for a long time
cold image to crop plants can be
minimized by introducing genes for
antifreeze proteins found in the blood
of Arctic fishes frost restrains
Tomatoes has been produced by
introducing genes for antifreeze
proteins from polar fish living in ice
water one biotechnology can help to make
intensive agriculture less damaging to
environment as well as help the country
to spend less money on fertilizers
pesticides and herbicides now come to
benefits and controversies on g---men GM
products first men will take benefits
for crops enhance taste and quality
reduced maturation time increased
nutrients field and stress tolerance
improved resistance to disease paste and
herbicides new products and growing
techniques benefits for animals
increases
since productivity hardness and feed
efficiency better yield of meat eggs and
milk improved animal health and
diagnostic methods for environment
friendly bio herbicides and bio
insecticides conservation of soil water
and energy bio processing for forestry
products better ritual waste management
more efficient processing benefits for
society increased food security for
growing populations now come to the
controversies for safety potential human
health impact that means electrons
transfer of antibiotic resistance
markers unknown effects potential
environment in fact that is unintended
transfer of transistor cross pollination
unknown effects on other of organisms
and loss of flora and fauna biodiversity
next xsn intellectual property
domination of bulk food production by a
few companies increasing dependence on
industrialized nations by developing
countries biopiracy that is foreign
exploitation of natural resources
now next is ethics violation of natural
organisms intrinsic values tampering
with nature by mixing genes among
species objections to transferring
animal genes in plants and vice versa
stress for enemy labeling not mandated
in some countries for example United
States mixing GM crops with non-gm
confounds labeling attempts
for society new advances may be skewed
to interest off rich countries before we
wrap up we would like to recap the main
points that is what you have learnt
sustainable agriculture systems are
those that are least toxic and least
energy consuming yet maintain
productivity and profitability
agricultural practices like crop
rotation intercropping polyculture and
proper soil management with mulches and
cover crops to maintain soil moisture
are integral part of sustainable
agriculture bio fertilizer are the plant
nutrients for of biological origin like
algae bacteria fungi which have no
harmful effect on soil and environment
organic farming is a type of agriculture
which avoids synthetic inorganic
fertilizers pesticides growth regulators
and livestock feed additives organically
grow and feed food products are free
from harmful chemicals or typical
flavors and preservation reiatives
vermicompost can be prepared at the back
yard of your home in one corner of your
school field or maybe in public park
which will produce many or as well as
clean up the environment from garbage
accumulation integrated pest management
is a grand idea to control pests and
diseases this increases production takes
the environment from pollution and
harmful effect of pesticides and save
money which is usually spent on buying
pesticides biotechnology technique is
used to produce plants by gene transfer
which can be a direct answer to grow
plants resistance to diseases paste told
in to coal taught and flooding etcetera
one can design a plan to suit this
condition dear learners this is all
about lesson 21 concept of sustainable
agriculture we will
I came to meet you with a new program of
environmental science thank you